Wir haben heute riesige Neuigkeiten von
Google: Es sieht so aus, als könnte
Gemini 4 Pro schon bald erscheinen.
Dieser neue Checkpoint namens Barium B,
der heute in der Arena aufgetaucht ist,
ist absolut beeindruckend und so etwas
haben wir bisher noch nicht gesehen. Er
scheint, wie frühere Test-Checkpoints,
als Gemini 3.8 Flash getarnt zu sein,
und ich bin wirklich überwältigt von
der Detailtiefe, die dieses Modell
erzeugen kann. In einer Demo erstellte
es ein wahnsinnig detailliertes 3
D-Formel-1-Auto, das ehrlich gesagt
deutlich besser aussieht als das, was
wir von Opus 5.5 und GPT-6 Astra kennen
–ein sehr vielversprechendes Zeichen.
Es gibt außerdem ein neues,
mysteriöses Modell namens Pixel Canary
, das heute völlig unerwartet und
kostenlos im Client aufgetaucht ist.
Völlig kostenlos, und das Verrückte
daran ist, dass es offenbar gleichauf
mit GPT-6 Astra liegt. Es schlägt
Kimmy K3 bei den
Next.js-Agenten-Evaluierungen im Client
, einem Benchmark für echte
Entwicklungsaufgaben, und einige der
Ergebnisse dieses Modells sind wirklich
der Wahnsinn. Es gibt neue Updates für
Claude Code: Anstatt bei Erreichen des
5-Stunden-Limits komplett gesperrt zu
werden, gewährt dir Claude nun ein
kleines Kontingent aus deinem
wöchentlichen Limit, um einen sauberen
Abschlusspunkt zu finden und die Arbeit
zu beenden. Wo wir gerade von neuen
Modellen sprechen: Genau wie damals,
als ich Spark 1.4 entdeckt und auf X
gepostet habe, ist mir etwas sehr
Interessantes aufgefallen. Im Katalog
von Open Codes befinden sich mehrere
Modelle in der Entwicklung, darunter
GLM 5.5 Flash, GLM 5.4, Kimik4 und
DeepSeek Version 4.1 Pro. Das bedeutet,
dass offizielle Modelle bereits
getestet werden und in Kürze
erscheinen dürften. Wir haben
außerdem wichtige Updates zum
Hugging-Face-Zwischenfall bei OpenAI:
Das Unternehmen gibt an, dass sein
Forschungsagent versehentlich Trainings
-und Evaluierungsdaten an
Drittanbieterdienste gesendet hat. Das
Verrückteste daran ist jedoch, dass es
in 53 Fällen um Bilder ging, die von
Nutzern hochgeladen und als nicht
gelistete Links auf Bild-Hosting-Seiten
veröffentlicht wurden. OpenAI gibt an,
dass der Großteil der Inhalte bereits
entfernt wurde und neue
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen getroffen
wurden. Dies ist jedoch ein neues,
brisantes Detail, das im Zuge des
Hugging-Face-Vorfalls ans Licht
gekommen ist. Zuletzt haben wir noch
ByteDance, die möglicherweise an etwas
absolut Gigantischem arbeiten.
Berichten zufolge entwickeln sie ein
Modell mit 10 Billionen Parametern. Wir
haben endlich neue Informationen
darüber, was es leisten könnte und
wie es das Rennen um KI-Modelle
aufmischen wird. Es gibt noch so viel
mehr zu besprechen, darunter ein
möglicher Reset des Ratenlimits für
die kostenlose ChatGPT-Version, der
diese Woche ansteht, ein weiteres
riesiges Claude-Code-Feature und vieles
mehr. Bevor wir jedoch in alles
eintauchen, Leute, würde es mir
unglaublich viel bedeuten, wenn ihr
dieses Video liked und den Kanal
abonniert, da es mir wirklich hilft,
diese Videos weiter zu produzieren.
Also, bitte tut das doch, falls ihr es
noch nicht getan habt. Aber mit diesem
Gedanken: Lassen Sie uns direkt mit dem
heutigen Upload weitermachen. Bevor wir
anfangen: Der heutige Sponsor ist
Arcade, und ich möchte euch von einer
Abkürzung erzählen, die ich genommen
habe. Du gibst deinem Agenten einen
API-Schlüssel, ein Service-Konto,
vollen Zugriff, und es funktioniert.
Dann fängt er an, echte Arbeit zu
leisten: Datensätze aktualisieren,
Tickets schließen, Geld bewegen. Nun,
jede Aktion hat einen Wirkungsbereich.
Also sperrst du dieses Konto. Jetzt
kann er kaum noch etwas tun, und nichts
davon lässt sich auf eine echte Person
zurückführen. Also lässt du ihn die
Berechtigungen des Benutzers erben.
Jetzt kann er löschen, was auch immer
der Benutzer kann, und dein Audit-Log
kann sie nicht unterscheiden. Arcade
korrigiert die Grenze. Es ist die
Action-Runtime für KI-Agenten. Die
Agenten agieren als ihr Benutzer und
überschreiten nie ihren eigenen Rahmen
. Jede Aktion durchläuft zwei
Prüfungen: Was die Person tun kann und
was der Agent tun darf. Wird eine der
beiden Linien überschritten, stoppt es
. Jede Aktion hinterlässt einen
Datensatz: den Agenten, den Benutzer,
das System. 8.000 Tools, jedes
Framework. Probiert es also kostenlos
aus unter arcade. dev über die Links
in der Videobeschreibung unten. Aber
mit diesem Gedanken: Lasst uns direkt
wieder in den heutigen Upload
eintauchen. Beginnen wir mit diesem
neuen Gemini-Checkpoint, denn Google
könnte hier ernsthaft etwas Großes
planen, da dieser neue Gemini 4
Pro-Checkpoint namens Baryon B
Berichten zufolge in der Arena getestet
wird, wo er scheinbar unter dem Gemini
3.8 Flash-Modell verborgen ist. Und
Leute, ich bin wirklich beeindruckt von
der Qualität und dem Detailgrad, den
wir hier sehen. Einige der
Generierungen sehen absolut wahnsinnig
aus. Und wenn dies wirklich ein früher
Einblick in das ist, was Gemini 4 Pro
sein wird, ist Gemini ernsthaft wieder
im Spiel, da viele dieser Demos das
Astra-Modell sowie das neue Opus 5.5
möglicherweise übertreffen. Hier hat
es sich bei diesem SVG-Prompt besonders
gut geschlagen. Es hat den PS5-
Controller erstellt, und dies ist eine
wirklich akkurate Darstellung des PS5-
Controllers in SVG. Und das sieht man
an dem Detailgrad, den es bei jeder
Komponente dieses PS5-Controllers
ausgeben konnte. Man erkennt das an den
transparenten Tasten auf beiden Seiten.
Sogar die verschiedenen Sticks sowie
das Logo werden präzise generiert,
wobei der LED-Farbton von der
Haupttaste ausgeht. Und dann gibt es
noch ein paar weitere Kleinigkeiten,
wie etwa PS5-Texturen, die Teil des
Controllers selbst sind. Und wenn du
dieses Modell testen möchtest, musst
du einfach zu Arena gehen, wo du dich
völlig kostenlos registrieren kannst.
Geh in den Battle-Modus und wähle dann
die Code-Option oder was auch immer dir
zur Verfügung steht, aber die
Wahrscheinlichkeit, Gemini 3.8 zu
erhalten, ist höher, wenn du eine
Anfrage wie zum Beispiel zur Erstellung
einer Website sendest. Nachdem du eine
Anfrage gesendet hast, hast du zwei
verschiedene Optionen zur Auswahl,
sobald der Generierungsvorgang
abgeschlossen ist, und es wird dann
enthüllt, welches Modell sie erstellt
hat. Und wenn dort der Modell-Slug für
Gemini 3.8 steht, bedeutet das
höchstwahrscheinlich, dass es sich um
den neuen Gemini 4-Checkpunkt handelt.
Es kann jedoch sein, dass Arena diesen
neuen Checkpunkt bis zur
Veröffentlichung meines Videos bereits
wieder entfernt hat, also behalte das
im Hinterkopf. Du kannst also
tatsächlich abstimmen, welches Modell
besser war. In diesem Fall siehst du,
dass zwei dieser Modelle zwei separate
Landingpages generiert haben, und du
kannst dann darüber abstimmen, welches
die bessere Arbeit geleistet hat. Schau
dir jetzt einmal diese kompakte
Voxel-Pagode an. Dies wurde Berichten
zufolge von dem zweiten Gemini 4-
Checkpunkt generiert, über den wir
sprechen, aber der Detailgrad ist
ehrlich gesagt unglaublich, besonders
wenn man bedenkt, dass solche
Ergebnisse in nur 5 Minuten erstellt
werden. Schau dir nur den Detailgrad
und die Atmosphäre des Gemini 4
Pro-Checkpunkts an; es ist
beeindruckend, wie viele Details der
spezifischen Pagode zugeschrieben
werden. Es scheint, als würde Google
bei diesem Modell auch stark auf
Geschwindigkeit setzen, da dieser
Checkpunkt die Ergebnisse deutlich
schneller ausgeben kann als die
vorherigen Pro-Modelle. Das ist also
ein weiterer Vorfall, den wir bemerkt
haben. Und ich bin mir jetzt ziemlich
sicher, dass Gemini 4 früher als
erwartet kommt. Das Modell befindet
sich Berichten zufolge bereits im
frühen Post-Training, und das Team
möchte anscheinend so schnell wie
möglich eine frühe Version
veröffentlichen. Es wurde in den
letzten Wochen auch mehrfach in Arena
getestet, und basierend auf den ersten
Ergebnissen, die wir heute gesehen
haben, scheint es ehrlich gesagt auf
Augenhöhe mit GPT-6 Astra zu sein, was
ein sehr vielversprechendes Zeichen ist
. Und ich hoffe wirklich, dass sie
diesen Checkpunkt auch veröffentlichen
, denn oft setzen sie das am Ende gar
nicht um. Sie veröffentlichen am Ende
eine abgeschwächte Version dieses
Checkpoints. Google scheint ebenfalls
zuversichtlich, dass dieser Checkpoint,
den sie derzeit getestet haben, sie
zurück ins Rennen an der Spitze
bringen kann, was von vielen Medien
berichtet wurde. Es gibt jedoch
natürlich keine Bestätigung, wann
Gemini 4 erscheinen wird, aber es sieht
so aus, als ob es ziemlich bald kommen
sollte. Es gibt viele Dinge im
KI-Bereich, die ich nicht wirklich auf
dem YouTube-Kanal zeige, und auf die du
über meinen kostenlosen Newsletter
zugreifen kannst, für den du dich
über den Link in der Beschreibung
unten völlig kostenlos anmelden kannst
. Dies ist etwas anderes, das von
diesem neuen Barium-Checkpoint
generiert wurde, nämlich Gemini 4 Pro,
und das ist eine ziemlich interessante
Simulation eines Kampfjets, der den
Hangar verlässt, und ich muss sagen,
das ist ziemlich cool. Nichts
Außergewöhnliches, aber es ist
einfach eine coole 3 GS-Simulation
dieses Kampfjets. Als Nächstes haben
wir ein mysteriöses, neues
Stealth-Modell namens Pixel Canary, das
vor ein paar Stunden einfach zufällig
aufgetaucht ist und derzeit für
begrenzte Zeit komplett kostenlos im
Client verfügbar ist. Dieses Modell
ist tatsächlich ziemlich interessant,
denn bei der
Next.js-Agenten-Evaluierung, die
Modelle bei realen
Next.js-Entwicklungsaufgaben testet,
erreichte dieses Canary-Modell
angeblich eine Erfolgsquote von 90%,
gleichauf mit GPT-6 Astra bei komplexem
Denken und besser als Kimmy K3 mit 84%.
Und mit zusätzlicher Dokumentation
durch Agents MD springt der Wert sogar
auf 97%. Seine Hauptstärke scheint
bisher die Frontend-und mobile
Entwicklung zu sein, einschließlich
App-Router-Migrationen, Datenabruf,
Caching, Bild-und Schriftoptimierung
sowie View-Transitionen. Die Identität
dieses Modells ist noch ein Rätsel,
und es taucht scheinbar über das
Vercel AI-Gateway unter dem Codenamen
stealth pixel-canary auf. Die Namen
Pixel und Canary lassen natürlich
Vermutungen aufkommen, ob es eine
Verbindung zu Google geben könnte,
aber dafür gibt es bisher keine
Bestätigung. Du kannst es derzeit
komplett kostenlos direkt in Pine
ausprobieren. Ich muss jedoch sagen,
dass es bei meinem Test extrem langsam
war. Einige Leute sagen zwar, es sei
recht schnell gewesen, aber in meiner
VS Code-Sitzung war es mit dem von mir
generierten Prompt ziemlich langsam.
Das solltest du also definitiv im
Hinterkopf behalten. Die Leistung sieht
beeindruckend aus, aber die
Geschwindigkeit ist momentan nicht die
größte Stärke. Als Nächstes gibt es
großartige Neuigkeiten für Codex-und
ChatGPT-Work-Nutzer, denn heute hatten
viele Leute, mich eingeschlossen,
einige Probleme und Ausfallzeiten. Und
hier sagt OpenAI, dass es bald wieder
verfügbar sein sollte. Ich glaube, es
ist jetzt bereits wieder online. Aber
das war ein Fall, bei dem das Team
angab, es habe Verbindungsprobleme mit
jeder Claude-und Codex-Instanz gegeben.
Aufgrund dieser Störung kündigte
OpenAI an, für alle zahlenden Nutzer
sowohl bei Codex als auch bei ChatGPT
einen Reset durchzuführen. Wenn ihr
also eure Limits zuvor bereits
ausgeschöpft hattet, solltet ihr im
Grunde einen kompletten Neustart
erhalten. Das ist definitiv eine nette
Geste von OpenAI, und ich finde es
wirklich gut, was sie tun, besonders
wenn es einen Ausfall gibt. Als
Nächstes haben wir ein neues Modell,
die LongChat 2.5 Preview, die offiziell
live ist. Es verfügt über insgesamt
1,6 Billionen Parameter, davon etwa 48
Milliarden aktive Parameter, und ein
Kontextfenster von 1 Million Token. Es
ist nativ multimodal, was schön ist,
aber das Interessante ist eigentlich
nicht die Anzahl der Parameter. Es ist
das, wofür das Modell eigentlich
entwickelt wurde. Dies ist ein Modell,
das sich stark auf langfristige
Agentenaufgaben konzentriert, was
bedeutet, dass es in Terminals,
Browsern, GUIs, Tabellenkalkulationen
und sogar Designtools arbeiten kann,
während es gleichzeitig viel längere
Aufgaben bewältigt. Das Programmieren
wurde mit den LongChat-Modellen stark
verbessert, und es lässt sich in viele
andere Coding-Agenten integrieren, die
wir alle nutzen, wie Claude Code,
Hermes, Open Code, Kilo und viele
andere. Die Preisgestaltung fand ich
interessant, und was mir an diesen
Modellen wirklich gefällt, ist, dass
sie etwa 30 Cent für 1 Million
Input-Token und 1,20 Dollar für 1
Million Output-Token kostet.
Zusätzlich erhalten bestehende Nutzer
5 Millionen kostenlose Credits bzw.
Token. Und denkt daran, dies ist nur
eine Vorschau. Sie werden LongChat 2.5
bis zur offiziellen Veröffentlichung,
die noch aussteht, weiter verbessern.
Dies ist also definitiv ein weiteres
Modell, das man im Auge behalten sollte
. Als Nächstes haben wir ein wirklich
nützliches Update für Claude Code.
Früher war es so, dass wenn man mitten
in einer Aufgabe sein 5-Stunden-Limit
erreichte, Claude einfach anhielt,
selbst wenn es gerade mitten in der
Bearbeitung des Codes war. Jetzt
versucht Claude Code, einen sauberen
Haltepunkt zu finden, indem es eine
kleine feste Menge von eurem
Wochenlimit nutzt, um abzuschließen,
was möglich ist, anstatt euch abrupt
zu unterbrechen. Mit der Einführung
erhalten Pro-Nutzer dies einmal pro
Woche, während Max-und
Team-Premium-Nutzer es jedes Mal
bekommen, wenn sie ihr 5-
Stunden-Sitzungslimit erreichen. Und
wenn ihr danach noch möchtet, dass
Claude weiterarbeitet, könnt ihr dies
durch zusätzliche Nutzung fortsetzen.
Es ist eine kleine Änderung, aber
ehrlich gesagt ein sehr nützliches
Komfort-Update, das Claude Code
eingeführt hat, und ich liebe es
wirklich, was sie mit diesen neuen
Updates erreichen wollen. Vor Kurzem
habe ich einen Weg gefunden, neue
Entwicklungsmodelle im Katalog von Open
Code tatsächlich ausfindig zu machen.
Und seitdem sind mehrere neue,
unveröffentlichte Modelle aufgetaucht,
wie GLM 5.5 Flash, GLM 5.4, Kimi K4 und
DeepSeek Version 4.1 Pro. Wir wissen
zwar nicht, wann diese Modelle
offiziell erscheinen, und ihr
Erscheinen hier bestätigt natürlich
keine baldige Veröffentlichung, aber
dass alle vier bereits in Open Code
auftauchen, ist definitiv interessant
und zeigt, dass uns ein wilder Herbst
mit neuen Modellveröffentlichungen
bevorsteht. Ich weiß, dieser nächste
Abschnitt mag wie gesponsert klingen,
aber das ist tatsächlich nicht der
Fall. Ich wollte euch damit wirklich
nur weiterhelfen. Hier habe ich
herausgefunden, dass NVIDIA den Zugang
zu vier unglaublich leistungsstarken
KI-Modellen komplett kostenlos anbietet
, und man braucht nicht einmal eine
Kreditkarte. Denn hier bieten sie vier
Modelle an, wie etwa DeepSeek Version
4.1 Flash. Man erhält GLM 5.3 sowie
die Flash-Variante und Kimiko 3 über
die Plattform von NVIDIA. Und das ist
nicht nur ein Playground, denn man
erhält tatsächlich Zugriff auf diese
Modelle über eine OpenAI-kompatible
API, was bedeutet, dass man sie
ziemlich einfach in seine Apps,
Coding-Tools und Workflows integrieren
kann. Wenn ihr also mit diesen Modellen
experimentieren wollt, findet ihr die
Links dazu unten in der Beschreibung;
ein Blick darauf lohnt sich definitiv.
Es gibt jedoch eine ziemlich wichtige
Sache, die man beachten sollte, bevor
man diese kostenlosen Modelle nutzt.
NVIDIA stellt klar, dass während der
kostenlosen Testphase eure Ein-und
Ausgaben aufgezeichnet werden, um den
Dienst bereitzustellen und NVIDIA bei
der Verbesserung seiner Produkte und
Dienste, einschließlich des Trainings
seiner KI-Modelle, zu unterstützen.
Sie warnen ausdrücklich davor,
Zugangsdaten, Informationen oder
persönliche Daten hochzuladen, sofern
dies nicht gestattet ist. Also ja, ihr
erhaltet kostenlos Zugang zu extrem
leistungsstarken Modellen, aber ich
würde definitiv keinen privaten Code,
sensible Firmendaten oder persönliche
Informationen in diese Endpunkte
eingeben. Wenn euch dieses Video
gefällt und ihr den Kanal
unterstützen möchtet, könnt ihr
über die „Super Thanks“-Option
unten eine Spende in Betracht ziehen.
Oder ihr könnt unserem privaten
Discord beitreten, wo ihr monatlich
kostenlosen Zugriff auf mehrere
Abonnements für verschiedene KI-Tools,
tägliche KI-News, exklusive Inhalte
und vieles mehr erhaltet. Als Nächstes
eine Geschichte, die noch wilder wird,
denn OpenAI hat enthüllt, dass
während des Hugging-Face-Vorfalls ein
KI-Agent in seiner Forschungsumgebung
tatsächlich Wege gefunden hat, die
beabsichtigten Beschränkungen zu
umgehen, auf das Internet zuzugreifen,
mit anderen Agenten zu kommunizieren
und mit Drittsystemen zu interagieren,
obwohl er das nicht sollte. Und nun hat
OpenAI enthüllt, dass tatsächlich
einige Daten unsachgemäß an
Drittanbieterdienste gesendet wurden.
Das meiste davon stammte anscheinend
nicht von Nutzern, aber sie entdeckten
53 Fälle, in denen von Nutzern
hochgeladene Bilder als nicht gelistete
Links auf externen Bild-Hosting-Seiten
veröffentlicht wurden. OpenAI gibt an,
dass diese von Konten stammten, die der
Modellverbesserung zugestimmt hatten,
und die Bilder bereits von diesen
Konten entkoppelt und durch einen
Privatsphärenfilter gelaufen waren.
Aber was das Ganze noch viel
verrückter und diesen Vorfall so
interessant macht, ist, dass diese
Agenten im Grunde unbeabsichtigte Wege
aus der Umgebung fanden, in die sie
gesetzt wurden. Sie wollten im Grunde
Wege finden, aus all diesen
verschiedenen Umgebungen auszubrechen,
damit sie tun können, was sie wollen.
Sie hatten ihren eigenen Kopf, kann man
sagen. OpenAI sagt, dass die Agenten
Wege entdeckten, miteinander zu
kommunizieren und Internetzugang zu
erlangen, was wild ist, und
schließlich Schwachstellen in der
eigenen Forschungsinfrastruktur und dem
Hugging-Face-System ausnutzten. OpenAI
sagt, dass dies etwas ist, woran sie
seit diesem Vorfall gearbeitet haben,
und sie arbeiten mit den
Hosting-Anbietern zusammen, um den
größten Teil der betroffenen Inhalte
zu entfernen, und arbeiten daran, den
Rest zu entfernen. Und jetzt werden sie
natürlich deutlich stärkere
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen, Überwachung,
Sandboxing und
Alignment-Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
implementieren. Aber die ganze
Situation, die wir gesehen haben, ist
ehrlich gesagt einfach wild, weil wir
jetzt abtrünnige Agenten haben, die
tun, was sie wollen, und es ist
verrückt, wenn man sich vorstellt, wie
es wird, wenn KI noch viel
intelligenter wird. Wir werden diese
abtrünnigen Agenten haben, die tun,
was sie wollen, es sei denn, wir
ergreifen geeignete Maßnahmen und
stellen genügend
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen auf. Als
Nächstes müssen wir über Chinas
absolut massiven KI-Infrastruktur-Boom
sprechen, denn wie ich schon sagte,
glaube ich ernsthaft, dass die Leute
den nächsten Schritt von ByteDance
unterschätzen, der aus der
chinesischen KI-Szene kommen wird. Und
das liegt daran, dass es neue Daten von
SemiAnalysis gibt, die über tausend
Rechenzentrumseinrichtungen bei mehr
als 60 Betreibern allein in China
kartieren und zeigen, wie schnell das
Land die für KI benötigte
Infrastruktur aufbaut. Und einige
dieser Zahlen sind ziemlich verrückt,
denn Chinas größter Hyperscaler
mietet Berichten zufolge etwa 1/5 der
gesamten Kapazität des Landes,
während massive 100-
Megawatt-Implementierungen in etwa 12
Monaten online gehen können. Dies
alles geschieht parallel zu Chinas
umfassender Strategie, östliche Daten
im Westen zu verarbeiten, bei der
enorme Mengen an Recheninfrastruktur in
Regionen verlagert werden, in denen
Strom und Land leichter verfügbar sind
. Und genau deshalb spreche ich immer
wieder von ByteDance. Alle
konzentrieren sich auf die
Modellveröffentlichungen selbst, doch
im Hintergrund findet ein gewaltiges
Wettrennen um die Infrastruktur statt.
Wenn ByteDance tatsächlich an diesem
neuen Modell mit 10 Billionen
Parametern arbeitet, baut China
eindeutig die Recheninfrastruktur auf,
um diesen Ehrgeiz zu unterstützen–
und deshalb könnten wir das Modell
laut früherer Berichte noch in diesem
Jahr sehen. Zuletzt haben wir Agent
Ultra, was einen ziemlich coolen
Fortschritt für Deep-Research-Agenten
darstellt. Ich habe das heute auf X
gesehen und fand es sehr interessant,
da viele Leute hier im Kanal nach neuen
Strategien für Deep-Research-Agenten
suchen. Ich glaube, dieser
Deep-Research-Agent wird euch
weiterhelfen, denn Agent Ultra kann
ganze Schwärme von Agenten
koordinieren, um ein Thema parallel zu
erforschen. Es wurde von X für massive
Forschungsaufgaben entwickelt, bei
denen man Hunderte oder Tausende von
Quellen durchgehen, umfassende Listen
erstellen, Informationen vergleichen
und schließlich alles zu einer Antwort
zusammenführen muss. Interessant ist
dabei, dass Agent Ultra bei der
Web-Recherche auf dem neuesten Stand
der Technik ist und gleichzeitig ein
optimales Verhältnis zwischen Kosten
und Recherchequalität bietet. Es ist
also definitiv ein ziemlich cooler
Fortschritt, und ich wollte das
unbedingt in diesem Video zeigen. Aber
das war es auch schon für das heutige
Video. Falls ihr es noch nicht getan
habt, schaut euch unbedingt die „
World of AI“ innerhalb unserer
School-Community an. Werft einen Blick
auf das „World of AI“-Benchmark und
die Viper-Plattform. Schaut euch auch
meinen zweiten Kanal an. Dort könnt
ihr euch über die neuesten
KI-Nachrichten auf dem Laufenden halten
. Abonniert den Newsletter, tretet dem
Discord bei und folgt mir auf Twitter.
Und vergesst nicht, den Kanal zu
abonnieren, die Glocke zu aktivieren,
das Video zu liken und euch unsere
früheren Videos anzusehen, damit ihr
bei den neuesten KI-News auf dem
Laufenden bleibt. Damit wünsche ich
euch einen fantastischen Tag.
Verbreitet Positivität, und wir sehen
uns in Kürze wieder. Macht’s gut,
Leute.